hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown at The Walking Dead Season
nine episode 16 the season finale titled
the storm for the past few years I
always thought Game of Thrones was doing
a Walking Dead impression and now The
Walking Dead returns the favor winter
has come so let's break down all the
details that you might have missed in
this season finale spoiler warning if
you haven't seen the episode yet first
off the final reveal which showrunner
Angela Kang even called a marvel style
post-credit scene ezekiel's radio
receives the mysterious transmission mmm
sounds like Captain Marvel to me
according to the closed captioning of
this episode she says hello hello
calling out live on the open air is
anybody out there
this word choice strongly indicates one
possibility and spoiler warning again if
you don't read The Walking Dead comics
this line is nearly exactly what you
gene says over the radio at issue 151
and he ends up connecting with a woman
named Stephanie who's from a new
community called the Commonwealth the
Commonwealth is a relatively advanced
community in Ohio consisting of 50,000
people with a concert arena and
stormtrooper II soldiers it's led by a
woman named Pamela many of us believe
that the character Georgy introduced in
season 8 could be from the show's
version of the Commonwealth and that's
where Maggie is there have been some
possible Commonwealth Easter eggs with
the word Commonwealth written on a
pinwheel and Toledo Ohio appearing on a
sign in the bridge building camp another
option is that this woman could be from
wherever Rick flew off to which could
also be the Commonwealth or another new
community or some are suggesting this
could be Alicia from fear The Walking
Dead since season 5 footage does show
them setting up some kind of radio
equipment or the show could just be
choosing to stay ahead of all of us
comics readers and sad hopeful fear The
Walking Dead fans alike and introduced
yet another new community here's hoping
that the newbies are more like the
Highwaymen than the garbage people
this radio reveal was set up at the top
of the episode which finds Ezekiel a few
months after the Pike it line describing
the kingdom's downfall the boiler and
pipes rupture a nod to Henry's past
maintenance now gone this EQ also talks
about fires and in the white shot as
Ezekiel departs you can see several
roofs burned out and one of them
surrounds the chimneys suggesting
someone was an idiot when it comes to
fire safety
looking at you Gerry also the risk of
using chimneys that haven't been needed
and so long it's explained later in this
episode when Eugene and the others
nearly get blown to hell know that smell
wasn't a dead chimney sweep chimneys are
just using were loosing kind of things
you might also be wondering why after
several years in Northern Virginia these
survivors only now experienced heavy
snowfall this region does experience
nasty blizzards about one out of every
three winters you think this would have
happened at some point maybe due to most
of the world's population dying out and
the end of industry and burning of
fossil fuels has led to a period of
global cooling or maybe they did have
snow when past years just no storm of
the century blizzards or maybe the show
just shoots in hot hot Georgia and
shooting outside in the snow is really
really hard unless he got dragon money
to burn this episode closes the book on
Ezekiel and Carol's marriage with the
two driven apart by their adopted son's
death this separation was actually
foreshadowed by the shot of the most
depressingly ironic wall quote at times
we crack only to let the light in which
was already cracked back in episode six
remember Carol first saw those quotes
back in season seven when she and Morgan
first arrived at the kingdom and met
King Ezekiel here Carol dumps the King
with the saddest breakup line this is a
nod to Ezekiel's proposal for her to
escape the horror of the real world by
embracing his fantasy illusion he's
telling these people a fairy tale maybe
they need the fairy tale now along the
kingdom errs Exodus there's another
interest in the Easter egg that you
might have missed but first thanks again
to Philo who sponsored this video this
season of The Walking Dead may be over
but there's still a ton of great TV to
watch with Philo Philo has made possible
my goal to cut the cord and switch over
exclusively to streaming services for
all my content it's perfect for me it
has over 50 channels including AMC and
Comedy Central it's by far the easiest
way to watch The Walking Dead you can
start watching within seconds I'm
actually gonna use it for fear of The
Walking Dead too there's unlimited
recordings so I can save as many shows
as I want and fans can re-watch the
entire season of The Walking Dead with
Philo's on-demand library Philo is
available on Apple TV Roku Android iOS
and fire TV it's simple and affordable
only $20 a month for all this content
I'm saving 100 bucks a month on my cable
bill it's great
Philo's really been the best solution to
stay cord free in commitment-free and as
a special offer for you guys the first
50 new rock stars fans to sign up using
our link will get their first month for
free just visit WWF Aiello TV slash new
rock stars that's pH Aiello TV slash new
rock stars okay back to that Easter egg
along the road they passed its top half
of a female Walker I think this is one
of many nods on The Walking Dead by Greg
Nicotero to the work of George Romero
Godfather of zombie cinema this time to
his 1985 film return of the Living Dead
there's one particular scene where they
tie down a similar female zombie
top-half to try to interrogate it why do
you eat people yeah this used to be real
fun but hey this is the walking dead
season where walkers start talking also
during this march Lydia tries to kill
herself since everyone hates her for
getting ten of their most expendable
friends killed her method is interesting
nearly allowing a frozen pond walker to
bite her Carol Caesar and Lybia pulls
away but this is actually exactly how
the comics version of Carol a very
different version of the character by
the way offs herself allowing herself to
get infected and to turn the group ends
up spending a night at the sanctuary
we're calling the first episode of this
half season episode 9 when negan spent
part of his prison furlough there
another subplot in this episode focused
on negan and Judith which calls back
their running gag they're all bored
shitless language with the solid turn
later
negan redeems himself somewhat by
rescuing Judith and dog which I love
because it's a callback to the negan
Judith moment back in episode six
when negan talked about how he used to
bring home dogs when I was about your
age I used to bring home stray dogs my
mom she hated it I always liked that
scene because negan kinda invokes
Judith's real father Shane alright let
me ask you so we asked you shot Andy can
kind of mask you Simpsons again - Judith
this episode I mean one of the kingdom
errs cross this frozen river careful not
to crack the ice which parallels a
dilemma at the opening of the season as
they cross the fragile glass floor at
the Smithsonian Daryl got an awesome
kill by using an icicle to stab Walker
through the eye which is a move lifted
directly from fellow badass John McLean
and die hard - this season has been
Bulova magis two iconic horror cinema
and they stuck in one last night at the
hilltop a sudden cut to this frozen
Walker the one whose head Darrel
shatters the framing is very similar to
the shot and the shining of Jack
Torrance frozen the death in the snow
and as unki Daryl throws snow balls of a
kid and his bata flogs alpha to keep
stronger Ezekiel makes an interesting
reference in his final speech we'll make
it through this win out of our
discontent
always the theater nerd Ezekiel is
alluding to Shakespeare's Richard the
third which opens with the line now is
the winter of our discontent made
glorious summer by this son of York
Richard is describing the Ascension of
his brother and were the fourth to the
throne Edward being both the son s o-n
of York and the son su in his moniker
being the Blazing Sun outshining Richard
a hated hunchback Ezekiel's winter of
discontent is the recent storm of this
episode the blizzard the loss of his son
the loss of his kingdom but his hope
here is sincere answered by a call over
the radio now going by the last time The
Walking Dead sent a mysterious woman's
voice through a device when Rick heard
the ghost of Lori through the phone I
think we could interpret this mystery
caller as a similar transcendent voice
from the heavens that we'll probably try
to murder them all in season 10 who do
you think is the voice on the radio
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at da
boss and subscribe to new rockstars
answer special news new rock stars would
love to go to VidCon this June
and if you plan to go and would like to
see us there tweet at vidcon to let them
know please like we'd love to host a
panel a live show a QA a meet-and-greet
really we just love to be able to thank
all of you in person for all of your
support
so let's light up those phone lines get
new rock stars at VidCon 2019 thanks for
watching bye